[Music]
Straight Ahead online crime daily three
strange when
one day you're
Cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds your Quasimodo Johnny Depp takes
the stand to telling his side of the
story in his multi-million dollar
defamation case against ex-wife Amber
Heard and my mother was
quite unpredictable we take a closer
look at Depp's direct examination how he
says an abusive relationship with his
mother affected his marriage to her plus
I will live with that
for the rest of my life
because of the allegations and because
it was such a high profile case
so I lost then
no matter the outcome of this child that
details how heard's op-ed article
allegedly impacted his career as
cross-examination begins then later
what happened herd's attorneys present
audio and video recordings showing a
glimpse inside Deb's Hollywood home long
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
foreign
to lawn crime daily I'm your host Brian
buckmeyer eyes and ears have been glued
to the multi-million dollar defamation
case this week where Hollywood X's
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard face off in
Fairfax Virginia in this special episode
of Law and crime daily we're
highlighting just a few of the
jaw-dropping moments from Johnny Depp's
testimony
but first a little background the 50
million dollar lawsuit brought about by
Depp against ex-wife and fellow actress
Amber Heard comes from an op-ed heard
wrote In The Washington Post in 2018
after their message 2016 divorce her
details being a survivor of domestic
abuse she doesn't name Depp in the
article but has repeatedly accused him
of domestic violence during their short
marriage that claims it was actually
heard who abused him
foreign
about six years ago
um
misheard
made a
some quite heinous and um
disturbing
brought these disturbing criminal
um
Acts
um
against
me that
that were not based in
any species of Truth there were
um
arguments
and
um
things of that nature
but never
did I myself reach the point of um
striking misheard in any way nor have I
ever struck
any woman since I knew that there was no
truth to it whatsoever
I felt it my responsibility to
to stand up not only for myself
in that instance but stand up for my
children it's been six years of
trying times
it's
very
strange when
one day you're
a Cinderella so to speak and then in 0.6
seconds sure
Quasimodo truth is the only thing I'm
interested in other
lives will get you nowhere but um
lies build upon lies and build upon lies
it's too much to cover I
I'm obsessed with the truth
all right Jesse welcome back from
Virginia based on what you've seen in
court do you think death is trying to
win this case or is this a way of
rebuilding his reputation
what a great question there Brian look
at one point I think his case is has
legal limitations legal Witnesses
weaknesses to it and it makes me wonder
why did he bring it the larger question
well does he want to rehabilitate His
Image you know he might lose this case
but if he comes off as so likable and
he's speaking not only to the jury but
he's speaking to the World At Large
perhaps he will get his career back
perhaps he will reinvigorate people's
reception of him the problem is there is
so many bad things coming out against
him audio recordings videotapes that at
the end of the day
and he knew this was coming out you have
to wonder what is he doing here is he at
the if he's coming off as so completely
honest and transparent that I'm not
hiding my drug abuse I'm not hiding the
text messages I did this I started this
I wanted the world to see it but I want
them to know that I was hit and abused
by Amber Heard and I am the victim maybe
in the end of the day that is what he's
hoping for but I think there are
problems in his legal case particularly
tied to the defamation of that uh
Washington Post article that could be a
really significant problem for him
convincing this jury that Amber Heard
found liable uh for what he claims were
falsities all right real real quickly
let's talk about that op-ed what if uh
there's an argument to say that it's
only partially the op-ed that ruined his
career not completely does that change
the analysis here in any way shape or
form
it has to all be the op-ed that's it if
he can't show the harm and damage came
from that op-ed you have to think he's
not going to win his decoration
all right we'll see how this goes but
hey he can change his old image think
about uh Robert Downey Jr from 1996 when
he had those gun and drug cases now we
all love him maybe that's Johnny Depp in
a couple of years we'll we'll see how
that plays out for him though thank you
Jesse we'll see you in a few moments
still ahead on lawn crime daily more
in-depth details about the tumultuous
relationship between Fame celebrity
Johnny Depp and actress Amber hurt but
first
is a need for conflict there's a need
for violence the only thing I learned to
do with it is exactly what I did as a
child the tree
Deb details his childhood on the stand
and the supposed impact his relationship
with his mother had on his marriage as
our coverage of the Johnny Depp verse
Amber Heard defamation trial continues
[Music]
welcome back we're continuing our
coverage of the high profile defamation
trial between actors Johnny Depp and
Amber Heard as a two x's square off over
a Washington Post op-ed written by heard
describing herself as a survivor of
abuse
depths now been on the stand for three
days ahead of Depp's testimony a jurors
heard multiple Witnesses describing the
relationship between Depp and his mother
Depp's sister testified last week about
the sibling's shared experience with
their abusive mother and how Depp would
often run off and Retreat while on the
stand Depp himself described his mother
and then compared that alleged abuse to
his relationship with herd
I had a very
interesting childhood
um one that I thought was normal until a
certain age my mother was
quite unpredictable
she had the ability to be
as as cruel as anyone can be and she was
quite violent
and she was quite cruel there was
physical
abuse certainly my
my personal experiences which I gave to
misheard
those those things were
those those facts were used against me
um
as As Weapons
it was not to help the relationship it
did not help the relationship it wasn't
meant to help the relationship it was
meant to feed her
um
need
for
conflict
which is a need for conflict which is a
need for violence
it erupts out of nowhere and uh
what I learned the only thing I learned
to do with it is exactly what I did as a
child
retreat
just take a step back but why did I stay
I stayed
I suppose because my father stayed
I suppose because I had been in that
relationship with Vanessa
and that was lost
and
I didn't
I didn't want to
I didn't want to fail
joining us today are our own celebrities
of course we've got co-host Terry Austin
and again lawn crime host Jesse Weber
Terry herds attorneys seem to be at the
very least suggesting that Depp is
capable of abusing herd but is that
enough to sway the jury
you know I think this jury is team depth
so to speak I think that the attorneys
are trying to portray him as being
violent being drug addicted being
verbally abusive but just because all of
those things are true he might smash
walls he may be addicted to opioids he
may drink a little too much he doesn't
consider himself to be an alcoholic but
he drinks a lot he thinks he holds it
well but none of those things really
mean that he beat his wife so I think
that the jury is listening to this but I
don't necessarily think that they are
buying it all he described one time they
were in Palm Springs with Kelly Sue I
think is her name and he couldn't
remember her name but he was protecting
Amber against this woman who touched
Amber and he was trying to say that he
didn't want anybody inappropriately
touching her so I think so far even
though they have shown he's up it on the
violent side it's not directed towards
Amber all right Jesse real quick Deb is
captivating on the big screen we know
that that he's obviously captivating on
the small screen as many of our viewers
at law and crime Network are watching
that live stream but you're in the court
is he captivating in person too
he really is and
especially because there is a very short
distance between him and the jury and
I've been watching them intently and
they are watching Donnie Johnny Depp
intently they don't really take their
eyes off of him unless of course they're
looking at an exhibit on their screen
this is somebody that is you're hinging
on every word he says because it could
either make or break his case and as for
everybody in the gallery like myself
gotta tell you there are times that we
are laughing and we are stunned by what
Johnny Depp is saying so it's almost
like a a mini movie I don't know what
kind of movie but a movie within a real
life yeah it's gonna be interesting to
see how this play out because they're
both actors and actresses
um are they going to lean to more of the
Harry Potter uh Pirates of the Caribbean
kind of vibe are they going to lean more
to the Aquaman I don't know but it's
going to be interesting to see how they
kind of battle that out when they're
both on the stand well we're going to
continue with this story thank you both
coming up on Law and crime daily our
Gabriel gavel coverage continues and the
Johnny Depp and Amber or defamation
lawsuit up next depth back and forth
cross-examination as he's asked about
the Washington Post op-ed article
[Music]
welcome back more now on the Johnny Depp
vs Amber Heard defamation trial in
Fairfax Virginia direct examination
wrapped up on a high note as Depp
testified on the op-ed written by heard
which started this case in the first
place
foreign
I'd say reading it and reading the
words that she had
written it was obviously referring to
our relationship it was obviously
referring to me did you experience any
consequences after the release of the
op-ed
you know we absolutely
[Music]
cross-examination of that kicked off
late Wednesday afternoon flipping the
script when the her when herd's attorney
asked about the article just moments
later
foreign
piece that's before you published in the
Washington Post she wrote then two years
ago I became a public figure
representing domestic abuse correct
I I can't say correct she wrote it and
the person doesn't contain your name
correct
no it does not no and other than
mentioning the fact of abuse accusations
that were made two years prior to the
publication of this article
the opinion piece doesn't contain any
details of your time together correct
oh I I think that her
um I I think it's very easy to write a
piece
and put the finger on someone without
saying their name
all right so Tara we saw that beginning
the cross examination there we know her
is going to take the stand and someone's
gonna ask her the exact same question is
this op-ed about Johnny Depp or not if
she says no it's another guy that she's
pointing to if she says yes it's Johnny
Depp how are either those answers gonna
change this case
you know what that's another excellent
question Brian and that's something that
depth team should absolutely ask her who
were you referencing here if you weren't
referencing Johnny Depp then who else
was abusive to you in your life and who
is that by name tell us all who are you
talking about and what violence are you
talking about she never mentioned anyone
else either in public or in writing to
my knowledge and it's a clear
implication that she's talking about
Johnny Depp she uses the time frame two
years ago everyone knows she was
referencing that tro when she claimed
that Johnny Depp was abusive to her and
I think the attorneys are trying to show
that depth is abusive his whole
childhood he's been dealing with it not
just as far as his mother is concerned
but also as far as his father is
concerned they made sure the jury knew
that the father had been violent as well
and punched him and Johnny even made a
little joke about the fact that it got
his attention so there trying to make
Johnny Depp out as someone who
definitely could inflict violence
against anyone frankly and Jesse that's
kind of my question for you Terry
touched on it just a bit there as you
look at the direct and cross-examination
of depth what do you think either side
is focusing on and which approach do you
think will win this case
well for remember his side they're not
only trying to win the defamation claim
they're trying to defend themselves
against hamburger's counterclaim so the
more that they can show that she was the
abuser and he didn't fight back the more
that they can show that she faked her
injuries that might be definitely a win
for him against the counter claim that
doesn't necessarily mean that he would
win the defamation case so again they
really asked to show that he did not
emotionally abuse or physically abuser
or psychological abuser in any way and
for her team they are trying to show
that this is a guy who was completely
out of control he derailed his entire
career before even before the Washington
Post article and Amber Heard was only
there to try to help him not hurt him if
there was anybody that there was an
abuser in this case it was Johnny Depp
that is what their side is really trying
to hone in on and I'm sure that they are
going to continue to do that when they
continue the cross-examination of Johnny
Depp now John uh no Jesse I gotta ask
you real quick which side do you think
is is leaning more to Awards winning
here Johnny or Amber
I think they're both going to lose
frankly I think from a legal point of
view I think he's going to lose the
defamation case that she's going to lose
the counter claim and at the end of the
day we're all going to be left with
their dirty laundry pieces all right
well I'm not doing other people's
laundries I've got my own and so we'll
see how that plays out as it continues
thank you Jesse and Terry when we come
back it's actor verse actress in a
multi-million dollar definition suit
still ahead attorneys present recordings
revealing insight into the relationship
between Johnny Depp and Amber hurt
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Lawton crime daily
continuing our coverage on the ongoing
Johnny Depp and Amber Heard defamation
trial now into cross-examination herds
attorney's Grill Depp Thursday on his
drug use and alcohol addiction and work
till and worked to point out
inconsistencies in his testimony
presenting text messages and recordings
of the couple
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
nothing happened this morning you know
that
that's you in the video Mr Depp right
that's correct sir and you would agree
that you were violent In that clip
correct clearly I was having a bad time
I don't uh I don't know what it was with
regard to completely at this point since
I don't know the date but um I thought
what was most interesting is that she
tried to hide it from me and then that
she
laughed and smiled at the end
I thought that was most interesting part
myself but so yes I did assault
um a couple of cabinets but I did not
touch misheard
testimony from debt continues Monday
lawn crimes Angela Levy will be live all
week as we bring you gavel to gavel
coverage
Terry what do you think of the video of
depth smashing things in his own home
and how he and herd react at the end of
that video
well you know I think anytime someone
tries to surreptitiously record someone
they are trying to catch him in a point
of time where he is violent and he did
not know that video was going I knew
from the second they started that video
because look at her moving that cup
making sure the video had a clear view
and then ultimately she tried to hide
the video when he came a little bit
closer so I think that clearly he's
being violent but not a single hand
touched her so for me it doesn't show
that there was any violence against
Amber herself against her person it
simply shows he was angry about
something and he took it out on those
cabinets and I think it was a little bit
of light humor on his part and I think
the jewelry probably appreciated that
yeah I think it's an interesting choice
of words I would have said he's more
frustrated in terms of throwing things
around violence has the connotation of
attacking someone which is very
different but we're lawyers that's what
we do Jesse there were two texts that
stuck out to me one of uh Deb apologized
heard's father and another about having
other uses for herd's throat to these
implications of abuse prove heard's case
or do they fall short
so it's a few things you can look at it
from Johnny Depp's perspective he has
very colorful language you know is he
actually being serious or not uh the
text that you're referring to is where
he he talks about that he won't do
injury to her throat implying that maybe
he had actually harmed her in the past
the text to the father to suggests that
you know he said Amber heard's almost
like an angel she did everything right
and that he's to blame for a lot that
happened but she also coupled that with
texts that where he continually
apologized to Amber Heard but to a level
where again it implies what did he do
did he engage in some sort of physical
violence but again for herd side any
form of physical or psychological or
mental or verbal abuse can be enough to
say that that is domestic abuse that is
enough to support her claim in the
Washington Post article and that in fact
she was telling the truth yeah it's
interesting because we're talking about
this Washington
um post op-ed and and all these other
things I haven't heard either side
specifically go to the language of that
op-ed yet it's more just kind of General
it's going to be interesting to see when
they get into the nitty-gritty how that
plays out well Jesse Terry thank you as
always and thank you for joining us here
on lawn crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss Justice in America
[Music]
thank you
[Music]